my
very good friend who's my first acting
partner in new york jessica menhas who's
the founder and ceo of i'll go first
which is an incredible platform for
trauma survivors and individuals who
have gone through really horrific things
to come and tell their story and go
first because
she and i realized in the work that we
do taking shame out of the room was a
big part of what we had to do and and it
required us to go first because shame
just
it's an illusion right it literally it's
like
it's like a dark room you turn on the
light one person turns on the switch and
everybody can see
and so
one person turns on that light and shane
just evaporates like the darkness and in
a room with a light on and so she
created that but she she
had been working fighting human
trafficking for years she was the first
one to educate me on this issue we end
up going to cambodia
i think i'm gonna go save children they
saved my life so now i have this why but
then i was projecting all of my problems
that i still don't know i have onto
these beautiful wonderful little girls
who were way wiser again children um
were way wiser than i could ever imagine
being and they are loving me and
compassionate and i don't know why i'm
being loved i wanted love but now i
don't know how to take it i'm like i'm
so confused so i go through that for
several years are you learning it you
haven't ever done it before so you were
learning it things that you would
normally do as a kid you're doing it as
an as an adult so you're you're aware of
the fact that it's not smooth you don't
get it it doesn't make sense it's not
easy it's not natural it's jagged happy
words come out wrong [ __ ] that didn't go
right this is what i mean because you're
learning because you're learning and
part of my learning i had to make amends
for because my coping mechanisms were
very interesting but i know that i
needed were they
one was i was a self-righteous little
[ __ ] um so i started doing this work
first i'm doing this
this you know i'm going oh after this
career for myself for me me me and then
i get there it wasn't enough so then i i
started educating myself on doing
something for the world but now i'm like
other people should be using their
platforms for the world like mitch you
started this like three minutes ago like
calm down um so i had i had a moment of
that
um and it was born out of me feeling
like a fraud dealing with imposter
syndrome
trying to cope with that but being an
incredibly defensive little human
and and other aspects of of myself were
that i could be extremely rigid i had
standards of perfection that were
impossible for me to reach let alone
anybody else in my world and i would
extend that you know anybody who was
close to me was an extension of me oh
yeah
so no no boundaries you know
oh i hear ya you know have you ever
heard of teal swan yes
i love teal and i learned this from her
it's just simple but what we judge in
others is what we deny in ourselves
no
judgment for all of those things that
people weren't doing that weren't good
enough or weren't perfect like because
you do it to yourself
absolutely absolutely so it was a lot of
that again still haven't had enough time
for cyclic seasons of life to
make themselves present in my awareness
and
when i was 25 i had this moment happen
with someone that i really really loved
and
it was just it smacked me in the face
and
i
it was the first time i ever realized
that i was the common denominator in a
lot of my problems
nothing like a little heartbreak to get
you there you know get right in there
i hear you girl
lord almighty i was like every here was
a thing though it was i had done some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like i've been a cheater
i've been a liar i was a pathological
liar in order to cope i had so many
survival skills man i'm like now i feel
like i would i'm a total like i'm so
rusty on all my skills cause like before
i had to be so vigilant and i was i
could lie at the drop of a hat like i
don't even i literally freeze if i have
to make up something i'm like oh sorry i
was gonna lie to you but i can't i'm
just like you know
i was gonna respond to you but i just
decided not to because i actually
enjoyed sitting in silence um so i know
that sounds like you're not important
but it's just that i'm a little bit more
important to myself right now
and people are like i don't know what to
do with this level of honesty like i
honestly don't know what to tell you
except that i all i know how to do is be
honest now um
but i was a pathologist
it's so much more effective it's so much
easier you don't have to remember
anything when you're honest you don't
have to remember anything if you're
honest that's what my my mom would
always say my grandmother said if you
tell the truth you won't have to
remember what you said and like i never
really resonated at the time but i'm
like thanks mom now i get it but so so
for me
this moment was really really massive it
was it was the moment that i turned
inward and as you said at the beginning
of our conversation
we go out there looking for the answers
everywhere in the external world and the
journey is inside the journey and the
journey is infinite once you turn inward
and yeah
i i was struck by something that
everyone was saying they kept saying
that um
they kept saying you did nothing wrong
in the situation like i'm so sorry this
happened you did nothing wrong you did
not deserve this and like normally
that's what you want your friends to say
right but i'm like that's not how my
friendships vibe i'm like listen we need
to call each other out on all of our
issues at all costs at all times and
they're like um i just need support
right now i'm like no here's what you
aren't seeing like my friends are like
oh god
i hear you it's just you can't you know
we're all wired different and we all
have you know we all have different
kinds of friends some match us really
well some are the opposite and you know
it takes all kinds of kinds it takes all
kinds of kinds and it's like for me iron
sharpens iron is the relationships that
i trust
so if you're coming at me and you're
saying hey i love you but [ __ ] what
are you doing like
that is you
you could easily
just be a yes man and this relationship
would just keep floating on
but you care enough to risk
me
that you would stand up and tell me the
truth that means
you're doubling down on this
relationship that means you're doubling
down on me and that means the world to
me that's how i see it so it's a little
it's a little reverse mechanics but it's
it's it's how you know in in again
trauma kids trust is a
it's a luxury we are not afforded so i
had to really find that and and that was
as a result of the emerald journey so
the amber journey started when i was 25
when everyone was saying that i i didn't
do anything wrong i was like this can't
be and all of a sudden i was like oh wow
i've cheated on partners i've done this
i've done that
it's just this was the one that mattered
this was the one that mattered the most
to me and i was in it to win it and i
got blindsided and i got to feel what it
felt like to be on the other side of
this and that is exactly the type of
friendships that i asked for call me out
the universe was like i'm calling you
out and i got called out and it was
painful it was excruciating i didn't
have all these experiences to be able to
know that cycles you know return
and so the journey inward i started i
just consumed books like four agreements
power of now everything written by
eckhart tolle everything written by don
miguel ruiz everything written by joe
dispenza you know like i just went
to my bookshelf over there going oh yeah
just like i'm sure i'll start listing
all the titles um
but just consuming this information and
then i was in a regurgitation of the
information phase which was you know
super annoying for people it's like
little misinsufferable know-it-all is
here to let everyone know the isotopic
wisdom that we're all lacking
still still a little on the
self-righteous path then absolutely on
the self-righteous path holier than thou
as [ __ ]
um but my friends are very long
suffering
very very grateful for all of you guys
all three of you um
small number quality versus quantity but
um yeah for sure but
then at at a point when i thought i had
finally
started to make sense of my life
i had gotten to a place where
i i was putting up boundaries i was
implementing them i had realized i'd
overextended myself years out and i made
a vow to myself that this one particular
commitment would be the final one and it
was the furthest out and as i completed
all of my commitments because i'm the
type of person who would like show up
dragging my dead ass self jet lagged
tired sick whatever i made a commitment
so i'm gonna stick with it and i was
like everyone was like it's so wonderful
you stick to your commitment something
isn't it and then i want to collapse you
know
your inner child's going we're dying
dude we're dying my inner child's like i
hate you
um
so so june of 2018 i finished that final
commitment outside of myself
two months later
two months almost to the day
following that event
i was in treatment for ptsd
and i had latent memories of childhood
sexual abuse return
and
it was
earth shattering i had lived for 31
years with one story and in a 90 minute
i said this all the time in a 90-minute
session my entire life story changed and
i was she was it a therapy session 90
minute session you mean therapist
session of emdr so my doctor
yeah she she's a specialist in eye
movement desensitization and
reprocessing for post-traumatic stress
disorder
specifically she works with women and
girls who are victims of survivors of
domestic and sexual abuse